la question des copies des copies de
disques les industriels ont été entendus
au moins partiellement par le
gouvernement le ministre de la culture
jean-jacques aillagon a présenté ce
matin en conseil des ministres un projet
de loi pour limiter ces copies de
compacts disques des copies pratiquée à
grande échelle grâce aux graveurs
incorporés dans les ordinateurs
explications céline crespy bruno lee
verte copier un cd rien de plus facile
il suffit d'un ordinateur d'un graveur
environ 150 euros et d'un cd vierges
en quelques minutes les musiques
transférer sur l'ordinateur sont
intégralement copié sur le cd vierges
coût de l'opération 1 euro quand un
album coûte chez le disquaire entre 15
et 18 euros pour limiter cette pratique
le conseil des ministres a aujourd'hui
approuvé un projet de loi qui légalise
des systèmes de protection sur les cds
une mesure qui satisfait les maisons de
disques c'est une base pour nous de se
dire est pour eux commencé à avoir des
moyens d'action contre le contredirait
la chute de nos ventes dû à une grosse
partie à cause du piratage car ses
copines coetzer aux maisons disent la
vente de cd a baissé de 13% cette année
par rapport à 2002 mais selon les
copieurs ce projet de loi ne résout rien
car la musique circule gratuitement sur
internet
et de cela la loi ne parle pas
vous ne résout absolument rien au
piratage puisque même si les cd sont
protégés contre la copie les fichiers
des morceaux donc circulent sur internet
la deuxième c'est qu'aujourd'hui un
utilisateur légal celui qui va acheter
un cd en magasin est pénalisé parce que
sur certains autoradios sur certains
contres ordinateur il n'est pas en
mesure d'écouter ses morceaux tout cela
ne mettra sans doute pas un terme au
piratage professionnels présents en asie
du sud est
un milliard d'albums aurait déjà été
copié il ya du travail elle